sí
[Música]
no
en estas colinas en el este de ruanda se
cultiva café azúcar caña y bananos
pero en los últimos años también se han
empezado a sembrar nuevas plantas está
por ejemplo es pachulí como kurt
isaac ingeniero agrónomo está a cargo de
esta plantación el pachulí se importó de
indonesia porque contiene aromas
poderosos perfectas para hacer aceites
esenciales si éste se porta lo más
importante aquí son las hojas porque ahí
es donde está
el aceite las hojas y es lo que más nos
viene a 0
en este valle empobrecido 210 personas
ahora trabajan cosechando estas nuevas
plantas
aquí geranio importado de sudáfrica
reciben un entrenamiento específico
antes de ser contratados los empleados
obtienen un salario mensual de 34
dólares un pequeño milagro para ellos
antes sembrábamos patatas dulces y
tubérculos aquí pero no podíamos
venderlos no teníamos ingresos
luego cuando llegó el geranio finalmente
obtuvimos un salario para pagar el
colegio de los niños la ropa incluso
para construir una casa buscaba
aburrimiento también podemos ahorrar
dinero para la jubilación
a lo largo del país el mercado de
aceites esenciales ha crecido de manera
exponencial estas mujeres llevan hojas
de eucalipto sobre sus cabezas que serán
transformadas en aceite
llegan para vender las hojas por kilo
[Música]
mientras
y
los locales reciben el dinero en
efectivo al final de su jornada de
trabajo el 90% de ellos nunca había
recibido un sueldo
anonymous las hojas cosechadas son
llevadas después a unos inmensos
alambiques calentados con leña para
obtener un litro de aceite esencial se
necesitan varias centenas de kilos de
material vegetal horas después las hojas
se convierten en el valioso líquido como
este aceite de eucalipto
nicolás y timaná es el pionero de los
aceites esenciales en ruanda está
orgullosa de haber podido desarrollar
este sector
cuando veo así es esencial es estar de
eucalipto geranio pachulí a
todos esos son recursos que tenemos en
nuestro país
todavía hay algunos por explotar y eso
siempre me motiva cuando
[Música]
el resultado media docena de aceites
esenciales que serán enviados a países
como eeuu canadá sudáfrica y reino unido
en occidente la demanda por estos
productos de bienestar está aumentando
exponencialmente
son utilizados en la industria
alimentaria y cosmética nicolás y timaná
espera poder exportar los aceites
ruandesas a parís francia es el
epicentro de la perfumería en nuestro
objetivo de penetrar en el mercado
francés
lo más eficaz
el año pasado el volumen de negocios de
los aceites esenciales en ruanda superó
el millón de dólares en los últimos
cuatro años se ha duplicado entre tanto
a áfrica sigue exportando estos
productos al mundo entero